Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's.
Now I have set up some acoustic panels.
To help make the sound a little less shit, so it's only slightly below garbage level.
Slightly above garbage, I'm sorry. I keep- I keep getting that confused, I live in garbage all the time.
Now comes the ultimate test:
Five Nights at Freddy's Tres (Three)
Which, as we all know, is the most douche-y of the Five Nights at Freddy's.
Maybe, I don't know.
I feel like that's a safe bet- safe assumption to make.
*hadooshski*
Alright, boink, boink, boink. Okay, push buttons.
Now this is gonna be the real deal. Unless something horrible happens, which is always po- Oh... hi. Oh! Hi
Hello?
I sure did!
Uh-huh.
I'm already workin' buddy.
Eh-heh?
Oh-oh fuck!
Oh... N-no *chuckles in fear*
aHAHAHAHA Shut up! Okay, we've got a problem right off the bat.
Um, excuse ME?!
IS THAT WHAT HAPPENED? IN THE REAL GAME?!
DID I HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS?! Okay fine, that's fine, that's all good, that's all well and good.
Um... we just have a gigantic problem, a big, BIG, big, big problem.
Okay, oh- wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ooh shit... interesting.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Wait.
Oh, oh shit.
Oh Oh oh, oh god, oh god, uh.
(mocking BB's laughter)
Oh fuck me!
Oh that is the worst thing I have ever seen in my life
Oh my god x1
Oh my god x2
Oh, my god x3
Oh m-  Oh my god x4
Ohm- Oh my fucking god!
Are you kidding me with that?!
(vent thumping)
WAAAAAH!
Oh my god! No no no.
(vent noises)
Oh! Oh! Oh!
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh!
HOoO- HOly, Holy shit
Okay!
Oh my god!
(Beeping)
Oh!
Oh what wha-
(Beeping)
WHA- AYE WOAH- I CAN'T BREATHE
OH WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT!
(Beeping)
Hey wait.
Hey keep the air flowing!
(Beeping)
CAN YOU SHUT UP FOR A SECOND!
Oh my god x10
Holy crap!
Okay.
Um.
This is officially the worst thing I've ever seen in my life.
(BB: Hi)
Oh my god!
There's a freaking vent!
Why didn't eh- I- I mean it never registered that there was a freaking vent there!
I mean of course there's a vent there, that makes total utter sense. Of course, why wouldn't there be a vent there
But I HATE THAT THERE'S A VENT THERE!
Oh my god, if I don't get them on that one then I'm dead! And if I don't get him he-
Where is he?!
Is he even in on the first night?
Is he gonna be in on the first night?
Oh shit! x5
Oh god, Okay.
Uh, night's almost over!
GAH
*vent noises* OOHAAH
Hey HEY- oh fuck, it's just...
That.
That-
THAT, is a tube of death.
that's j-j-just a tube of death
(music box sounds)
(kids cheering)
Yaaaay!
Foxy Cove Cooler, is this beer? I hope so. (Crunching)
Blah, I'mma die now, okay there we go.
Why do I have to sit directly adjacent to the tube of death?
Much like you! Why do you sit in this doorway of death!?
And you, and whoever else and I don't understand anything that's happening.
I don't know, okay alright lets go for it.
Buh! BUH!
Okay, buh, whatever- god, shut up!
I jus- I don't have time to deal with your shenanigans, there's..
Secrets to find!
Uh-huh.
Huh?
(BB: Hello?)
Ah, fuck, oh..
Oh, shit
Oh shit, okay. You, ugh...
Ah shut up! I get it I get it, I'm in a pizzeria but you-
Oh you sack of shit.
Ah, ah! I got, I got my EYES ON YOU! I got my eye! On YOU!
Okay, you're not gonna get away from me this time.
Oo, where you goin? I see you over there, you gonna try and get into the vent?
Well you can't, because that vent is BLOCKED!
That vent is BLOCKED! The tube of death ain't no tube of death!
It's the tube of LIFE!
Okay, alright, he's still there, which is fine.
Cause so long as I can see him.
(screams) OH GOD,  WHAT THE FUCKING FUCKER DUCK OF FUCK!
WHAT WAS THAT??
WHAT THE FUCK???
WHAT the FUCK- cable, get out of here!
Fuck..
C-coin! YaAay! (kids cheering) Yaaay!
Fuck, oh fuck where is he? Oh, I see you. No, don't try it, okay? That's still locked, that's still closed.
No one's gonna- I see you, fucking light.
You... (vent noises) okay.
No, where you goin? Yeah, where you goin, where you goin? Nahhh, yeayeayeayea.
Ah-na-na-na-na.
Ah-na-na-na-na-na-na
na na.
Na na na na. Na na na na.
What the fuck are those things?
What was that?
*Vent bang* what the fuck was that?
What the fuck-
They put...nothing here
What the fuck are you going?
Where did you go? Oh I see you.
Oh I see you
Ok, who the fuck
Who the fuck
Not today. Oh, not today.
I see you. Oh, I see you.
And I don't like you, but I see you.
Ok
We're good. Everybody hold onto your hats,
because this is going to be a bumpy ride.
Um, but that guy,
I remember playing this game and I was like
Ah! Just one. You know? Just one.
It aint-- Where? It-
Oh, there you are. Okay you ain't -
Oh you ain't, oh you think, oh you think
Wait...no sto--wait..wait. Oh you thi--
*Mark screaming*
OH what the fuck?! Sorry, sorry.
I get it now. I remember that.
That's the, uh, there is, um, aaaahhhhh
Theres uh, [unitelligable]
There's a buffet of death.
Raining down upon me. But I remember that.
I remember it very distinctly, *BB laughs* that uh- the-
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck
Oh, fuck.
Where is he?
Where are you?
Wait-
Where are you??
[BB] Hi
[Mark] Wait-
WAit, oh god.
WaIT.
Oh no, oh no. No, no, no. NO
Wait. Wait
No wait, oh go back, go back. Hi? [BB] Hello?
Hello?
Go back, go back, go bAck!
GO BACK!
*BB laughs*
AH HA HA
Oh fucking go back! Where did he go?
Did he go back? Ok, he's going back
So I just have to draw him. [BB] Hi.
[Mark] Go back, go back, go back, go back,
Back that green ass, uP!
*hello?*
Why don't you go bACk. You ain't gonna come down this way nO mO'
Gonna block you... shitlord... up! [BB] Hi.
You're like a drum.
...Why is he not moving.
He would normally be moving in this circumstance...
But, he's not gonna get that gate. That's for sure!
*vent noise* oKAy AGHWA
aHHHHHH, I REBOOTED ALL.
Okay, it's fine.
Uhmmm, he's- he probably went forward again.
So, imma just- *hAHAHA*
BLINDLY... ASSUME...
If I can keep him at five-
I think this strategy I re- *gaSp*
...Hi, buddy.
OKay, I- Well that's a bug, okay
This is good!
So, if I can force him back here...
If I can force him back, then everything's gonna be hunKy dOOdIE.
oHHh, everything's gonna be hunky dory.
Cmon, force back. [Bb] Hello? [Mark] YEaHH, yEahh whEre yOU goIN'?
yOU goIn' bACk?- Oh, shit. He's not going back.
OH FUCK, WHERE'D HE GO?
WAit, NO. IS THERE A VENT?
WAIT, WHERE IS hE?
hHHHhAuhH
Ye- wAAAIiT A MINUTE
oOOooo, WAIT A MINUTE
hOOOollLYYY- NO
NO
There we go.
Okay we- AAAGH DON'T LOOK AT mE
dOn'T lOOk AT M- AAAAGH
Augh, why did I look again?
Why did I look again? WHY?
Why did I look again?! I dunno why I looked again
HI! Hello!
Haw---shit
Ohh--God
Why did I look--
I thought he'd be gone after the first ti--
Shit that was a vent
Wait wait wait wait
He's in a--I--was that
HAAH! --oh fuck
Fuck this shit (3x)
*kids cheering* Yaaay!
It's the worst
That's the worst
That is the worst thing
Imma hide under this table for a lil' bit
That's the worst thing I've ever done
That is the worst thing (2x)
With this fist I do declare that is the worst thing I've ever done
Alright ok alright
Good. Great. This is great
I got a coin, which is good
And I'm paranoid now
cuz..uhh think I dont think I'm safe anywhere..
[YaaYY] Heeyyy! That's so good!
Greaaatt.. Hey,
you know what, you get a few sucker punches
to the TANK
A boink boink boink
Hooray... uh, huzzah...
Oh my god. We still rolling? Yeah, we are...
Oh, yeah we are.
Oh yeAh we areee
So, let's y'know
Let's keep the gravy train movin' baby!
Let's get right back into it
This is the w O r s t
I can't overstate how much this is...
the worst...
wha- was that??
*whispers* wonder if I can touch these... ah
*still whispering* I don't like this
this room
I have a funny feeling, they're gonna fuck with me
iN tHiS rOoM
*normal voice* I'm good! I'm good though, I'm-
ohh shIT too close.
Okay,
Alright.
Yeah, what up??
I don't care
Go away!
oh shit
s h i t
What was that?!
Oh oooh wait whaahaat wait whahah wait a minute!
Whoa, hey wait wait [BB] Hi~
go OvEr ThErE *springtrap screeches*
What happened??
What are we-
I don't know what happened-
Where are you?
Where'd you go
Wait! Wait, wait, wait, that's too close!
Oh god, oh god
Wait am I- wuh-what's happening
Oh hey, Go BaCk
OvEr ThErE
There's a good place for you THERE
[BB] Hello
WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT!
*screams* FUUCK
Okay, alright, fuck me, fuck me
Just go over there, go over there
Ohhh, fuck me!
Oh fuck... me
Oohh fuck, Go AwAAAY
HUUGH
Is it com-, I can't see.
Am I dead?
Am I dead, why am I blind??
Help!
Somebody... Help!
Did I die?!
[BB] *laughs*
WHY
I can't
I can't, there's nothing
I've got nothing
I've got nothing x2
Oh fuck
Fuck
Why am I blind?
I keep going blind!!
I keep going bLIIIND!
I- uh- aidu??
Uh, did the Oculus break or am I broke??
Oh fuck.
I-I think it broke
Did it break?
Am I- am I broke?
Is the cable.. hook up broke?
Am I..
What happened
I'm blind
I can't see, can you guys see??
Okay so
I'm still playing, guys alright,
this is terrible...
*whispers* Oh god
It's looking at me, isn't it..
I just, oooh
Oh fuck..
[BB] Hello?
AHHH, what did I do?
*whispers* Oh god, don't kill me
Oh god, there's still buttons
Oh
Wait
Wait what do I see?
I think I see something
Wait I'm seeing like a barely something
Did I like fall through the floor-AHH,WHY??
What?! OH, WHYYY can I WHA I SAW A LITTLE BIT
SO YOU'RE JUST FUCKING WITH ME
So, so you're just FUCKING with me!
Is that to be understood??
You! You're just fucking with me,
It's, oh m- you are just fucking with me
There, I can't see anything
Oh AHH AHH OH OH GOD
*springtrap screams*
Hey! Listen, buddy, listen
Okay I can see that- AHHH
*static*
*freddy laugh*
*sighs*
*breathes heavily*
Okay
*whimpers* Let's try again...
Cause why not?
Maybe I'll go blind again.
Audio devi- no no no no no no no god damnit
Oh fiddily diddily, fiddily diddily, fiddiliy diddily
Fiddle my diddle
There's my diddle fiddle
But I can't do that anymore
That's fine cause I'm fine
Cause everything is fine
Cause he's gonna get over here, I know it
I know it, I feel it, oh is he somewhere in here?
Where aohhh dere he is!
Wait! He's right there, that's good
Okay, um
Lets- AHH What? Noo, I'm not looking at YoU!
Noo I'm not looking at you
You know what, you know I'm not looking at you, I'm not
Okay so you're not gonna be there
So you're gonna stay right there [BB] Hi
Hi, yeah indeed
AHHH AHHHH
AHHHHH NOT LOOKING AT YOU
YOU'RE NOT REAL, you're not real, you're not real-
[BB] Hello? [Mark]- you're not real, you're a figment of my imagination
and if you're a figment of my *scared attempts to say imagination* [beep beep]
NOo, please ah
I think I rebooted all, please don't go- blind forever
I just wanna- don't, I just want not to go blind forever
Where'd you go? [BB] Hi
No, hey, where'd you go shhh shh
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buh-AHHHH STOP IT
STOP IT
sToP
STOP *BB laughs*
*moans*
*moans slightly louder*
*Probably pooping*
Okay *quiet again*
Alright buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
Where'd you go buddy
Okie, you're right there buddy, that's okay buddy
You're gonna go over here buddy
Hey come on. Oooo,
There you are buddy, okay hey buddy
How you doing buddy hey buddy
That's good to see ya buddy
Hey how you doing buddy, hey listen buddy
I don't like being in this situation buddy,
but I don't think you do either,
so maybe we could just reason with each other and try to get an understanding going between us buddy
so if we're just buddy buddy about this then no ones gonna be a problem about anything for nobody for nothing
'Kay where you going, hey no stick around buddy (buddy doesn't look like a real word anymore)
Hey I've got more stories to tell buddy
Hey listen buddy
You do AHHHH whabubuh that's okay that's okay
Yeah yeah peek over there what was that over there, that was weird that sure was weird
You heard a noise and there definitely was a noise over there so why not check that out
That's a good call on you, where'd you go, where'd you go
where'd you go, oh he's going in there that's good
because Imma-AAHHHH
fack! fack! FUCK OKAY I put that down there
So I'm gonna try and call him back here
And that's okay if he goes over there that's fine, I don't mind that
My buddy goes where my buddy wants to go
and where my buddy wants to go over there
but if he's not there
oh shit oh fuck oh shit
Is he in the vent X2
Where is he, I don't know where he is
Where'd he go? Where'd he gO
Wha- where- where did he go
He's gone
shit
oh fuck
Oh he's right there
I see you buddy, heey buddy, how you doing buddy
Hey it's good to see you buddy listen,
I see you in the corner over there buddy, I see your little tootsie buddy
that's good because ah my buddy buddy
we w-we we ain't got no problems
Heyy, where you going buddy, you going down here
*springtrap screeches* AHHHH WHAT THE FUCK
AHHH *screeches again* COME ONN
*panting* It's okay buddy
Hey buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
Listen buddy you ain't gotta have no problem with me
if I ain't got no problem with you, and I'm blind
*melodic tune* but that's okay buddy we're okay buddy
we're fine buddy, where'd you go buddy-
[BB] Hi [Mark] you're over there buddy
come to 8 buddy, it's gonna be real good *tune ends*
It seems like two of these gates are closed
which is kinda a boon for me [BB] Hello?
it's a little bit of a boon
I like boons
Boons are good
Can you go over there please?
I mean like really could ya
Okay yeah yeah yeah yeah, that was weird huh?
That was weird that was a weird sound, yeah weird about that
Okay alright we're good, hey buddy buddy
How you doing buddy?
Good to see ya buddy
How you been buddy, good buddy, good buddy
As long as- *gasp* fUck
NO not looking, you're not real, I don't care
You're not real I don't care about what yoooouu
You're looking at me aren't ya
No you're not, nahh you're not
Ookay we're good buddy, [Hi] hey where'd ya go buddy
Hey listen buddy what ya doing
What you doing buddy, heeeyyy
I got all this all- where'd you go
Okay you're over there come on [BB] Hello?
come on come on, go go go get dat ass movin'
*sighs* Oh my god
I think I've got this locked up
I think I do
I think so long as, I yeah he's coming back
so long as I get him bouncing between these two
He's, he's pretty okay
dats the thing, if I could, oh shit
if I've got him bouncing between the two, I'm relatively okay
so long as I do that, what does that do
I don't know what that does, oh I don't wanna touch it look like an on/off switch
so why would I want to press the on and off switch I dunno
[BB] Hello? [Mark] I have no- *6am bells* ahh
*sighs*
Okay
Alright
Alright, good, good
Thats good. Thats very good.
Good, good, good. Hey! Wow!
Oh, disappointment!
Alright!
Are you ti-oooh... Are you tired of intrusive flavor and texture in your food?
You ever eat a home cooked meal and feel silent dread?
Well boy do we have a snack for you
Dissapointment is neither new or exciting.
Not a single remarkable flavor will intrude on your food experience
Wow!
Take a somber, unfulfilled, breath of relief as you take a bite out of Disappointment.
This snack is not great, it's not even good. It is boring, mild, and passable.
Apparently 850 calories. Great!
It's *laughs* It's got 122% of your recommended fat. That's wonderful. I love that.
Oh. Thank you!
*Sighs* Ok, who do we have here this time? Hey, You've been surprisingly absent Mr.Rabbit!
Been a little bit on the-  on the not here-ish-ness. Which, ya know, which is a different experience than what I'm used to.
Okay
So I've got this on lock. The shock factor is over.
So now all that comes by is just me playing the game the way I know how.
Ya know, you can shut your face. I'm gonna keep it on reboot all.
We're gonna look for you. You're right here- [Hi] Come over here.
Close.. that one
And that one. Maybe if I can close multiple ones-
*springtrap screeches*
AAHHHHH WHAT THE?! FUC- FUCKING. GOD
Jus- hold your TITS- please where are you?
wait
WHered he go? WAIT  oh
Wherd he go?
WAIt I can't see! Can I see? Can I see? Can I see?
Where did he go, did he go in here?
Wait where did he go, wait where is he?
Wait- Where'd he go? WAIT Where- where'd he go?? Where'd he go?!
He's gone, OOOH
Do not. Don't. Don't think even think about it, don't even think about it, don't think about it, oh god don't think about it
Oh god. Where ARE YOU?!
Where are you? You're- you're in one of these, aren't you
Oh my god you are
Oh my god you're not. Okay maybe you're not
Or maybe you are, I don't know.
*spooky boy screeches* *Mark screams*
HOW ARE YOU THERE?! How are you there- LISTEN
[BB]Hi [Mark] HEY!
OH GOD! nONONONo
LISTEN  LISTEN listen
AHHHEY
[static]
[Mark's voice from before, distorted]
Shut up... shut up...
shut up..
mkay
He's not..
Nope. *screeches*
Nah, not today, not today, not today
You're still gonna come here,
Yeah that's right, come here, come here
Whoa, whoa, whoa *spooky sound*
Hey wha- WAIT- what happened? NONONONO
NONONONONOnoNoNonoO
What happened, what was that, what was that? What happened?
[hello?]  NonOnOnONo
NO!
NO! WAIT hang on stop!
YOU DONT wanna DO THIS-
LISTEN! I've been a good boy-!
I've Been A GOOD BOY, please!
I've been such a GOOD BOY
DON'T DO IT!
NOOOOOOOO!
Hi.
*springtrap screeches*
*static*
*Freddy laugh*
*computerized demonic screeching*
Alright.
Where'd he go? You're over there.
[BB] Hi [Mark] You're gonna go nowhere-  it got dark
Why's it dark?
No no no
OH the ventilation! Okay, its fine. It's fine!
Okay, so if if it goes SLIGHTLY dark *BB laughs* Then that's-
AUGH
OKAY ALRIGHT WE'RE FINE, WE're fine. Hey, listen,
Hey, there you are! See? [BB] Hello?
You ain't going noooowhheeree x2
You ain't doing nothing- goin' nothing go nooowhere
[BB] Hi
Okay... I've got this on lock..
If I just stay calm and collected...
If I stay CALM and COLLECTED-
*BB laughs* HeHEhEeeh,
YeA I'ma reboot preemptively because I'm...
I'ma-
AUUUGGH I'ma
Fucking stop that
Cause he- where'd you go? x4 Where did you go?
ohh THere You going, okay where'd- what're you
What are you doing down there? That's uh...
There's no vents down there.
Yeah, why don't you come back out here?
Yeah, come on back, there's no vents over there!
You dont wanna be there anyway, it's dirty.
It's getting dark, I don't know why,
but it's getting dark...
Just gonna preemptively do that.
Okay, you're going over there now and *BB laughs* now you're coming up here.
I'm gonna run ya in circle, I think this is the strat that I have
to beat the final mode of this one anyways, so lets keep it rooolling. Come on
*screeches*
ThAt hurt my eyeballs but I'm fine! Don't worry bout me!
Yeah, there you go, there you go. Where you gonna go? Where you gonna go? [BB] Hi
No where
Ohhh shit, uhh, its dark! Fix it please!
Fix it, fix it
Oh where are you, where- where'd you go? Okay you're right there
*BB laughs* Come on, come on, come on, come on
I'm playin with you now,  you dont know wh- AUGH-
ooooh FUCK OOOOFF With you FOXY
[BB] Hello?
oh SCRREWW you foxy man!
HOOOKKYYY BOOYYY
Yeah, that's right. [BB] Hi [Mark] Just keep bouncin', keep bouncin',
Yeah, keep bouncing, no I know there's something over there
Okay, there's nothin'. Is there anything in there?
Okay, there's not.
Yeaaaahh, that's right! That's what I thought!
Okay that's what I thought Mr. Man
[BB] Hello?
*screeches* AUGH FUCK fUck,
Why would that happen? Where'd you go, where'd you go?
Where'd you go, where'd you go
Oh, where are you? Where are you? Where are you?
I don't know, I'm gonna fix that,
I don't know where you are anymore *BB laughs*
I don't- I don't know where he is, I can't- I couldn't see him
Where is he?
Oh shit. Lost him. Okay why're you over there?
I don't know! But is there a vent over there?
I don't think so. I don't think that there's one.
Can you fix that already??
Okay, there's no vent over there, that's fine.
Okay, [BB] Hello? [Mark] I'm gonna call him here, this is gonna be risky.
This is gonna be risky, but I'm gonna try to call him, I'm gonna close this d-
*screeches* AUGH WHA FUCK
Okay, I'm gonna call him here,
*screeches* AUGH FUCKING COME ON
Call him! Here! Call him, call him, call him, call him
Oh, FUCK
OHH FUCK
OH FUCK
OH FUUUUUUUUCK
Call, here, here, here, here,
OOOOOHHHHHH
GO AWAAAYYY
shhhhh, I'm TRYING to not die
[BB] Hello?
Heyy, there's a noise over there you-
FAAAAAAAAK
*static* Fucking- I was-
ughhh
Alright, now I'm just pissed off.
Now you brought the thunder!
Now you brought the GUNS!
And now you gonna get it!
Oh, you gonna get it now,
oh you try, oh you TRY on mee
Oh you shut up! Shut- shut a-bam
Uh oh, he didn't like that, wait
Oh f- *screeches*
FUCK, FUCKING
Okay, that's fine! Cause that's all closed up!
That's all closed up!
What a stupid, yeah.
Why don't you just try to dump in there, huh??
Weird, huh???
Weird, oh shit.
*BB laughs*
Weird, where'd you go, where'd you go, did you go in the vent again?
Yeah, you're trying to go in there, but it no work!
That's so weird *vent sound* about that! Thuuunk
Stupid idiot.
Yeah, you stupid fool
Yeah what're you gonna do? Nothin'!
Oh,
Ehhhh, ain't gonna do nothin'!
Yeah, ya stupid. [BB] Hi~
Yeah, try going in there again!
Man, this is easier than I thought it'd be,
I think I found the exploit here.
Yeeah, this guy's so dumb he's got no brain inside
there that, the springlock's done scooped your brains out!
Did you lose all your smarts in the scoopin' room ya stoopid??
Yeah, that's what I thought, oh yeah where're you goin'?
Oh, nowhere!
Oh shit, where're you go- oh! Back in there again!
Like an idiot!
What a dummy!
I can't believe he's this- AHHH
Ookay, I can't believe he's just that dumb!
...where'd he go? Humm, where'd he go?
Oh, did he go- oh poor little baby! [BB] Hello?
Oh nooo!
Poor little baby, so confused in his brain!
*BB laughs* He can't figure it out!
I'ma just preemptively do that
I'ma a- oh, there we go, I needed to do it.
Ohhhh, whoopsie, [BB] Hi [Mark] Oh! What's that again?
That's right.
Come back, come back, come back, oh no no no
Come back. Come back, come back, [BB] Hello?
[Mark] Come back, no no no, hey
listen, I was just joshing about all those jokes before
Come back over here!
Hey! Hey buddy! Hey buddy!
Heyyy buddy hey!
Hey buddy? Hey buddy, you wanna come back there?
You wanna come back there?
Yeah, yeah, oh yeah you- [BB] Hello? [Mark] stupid idiot!
Oh you stupid-
Maybe try the vent again you big dumb idiot!
Oh you big-toothed, big-eyed, stupid moron!
Oh, you full of bolts up inside that head of youses
I'll look- AAHHHG
Oh fuck,
Okay, alright, okayy we're not joking around here
Alright, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine
[BB] Hello? [Mark] Oh hello?? Ah huh huh hello?
Maybe I am joking because this guy's a clown!
HehhehhEH!
Look at this idiot, *BB laughs*
Ahuhuhuh! Maybe try the vent one more time you goof!
Alright, anybody over there? Okay, it good.
[BB] Hello? [Mark] Are you in the vent??
Oh shit, he's not in the vent
Oh, uh, nOooo, don't do do do go go
[BB] Hi [Mark] Hey! Why don't you go back?
Hey, why don't you go back? Why don't you go back?
You wanna go back. *BB laughs* You wanna go back
Yeah, you wanna go back
C'mon, you wanna go back. Oh he's goin' back,
This stoopid IDIOT!!
The big dum-dummy here!
Ahhh, he's ain't so scary down there.
He ain't so scaryyyyy! [BB] Hi
Oh you stupid, oh you too stupid from this,
I'm too smart for you! Alright gimme a secret!
Gimme a *ding dong* Aughhh there we go!
YES!
HA! HA! HA! I kicked your ass!
I kicked you ass with my big brain and you're too stupid to figure out how stupid you are!
Gimme my prize!
Boink! I love it!
Oh, wait, no, I don't love it
Wait, what is that? Wait. What the fuck.
Wait, no I- I don't- I don't
I don't love that. Wait why?
I-
Can I- ?
I don't-
Thi-
I don't. I don't love this at all, I
...I don't want that.
That's... Not good.
RrrARARARARAR
RRAARAAR
Oh you ain't so tough now that you small huh?
*as Freddy* Oh no, not the fist of doom!
Oh, I'm sorry, this is the fist of-
The- um- ah- the OTHER fist the fist of doom!
THIS IS THE FIST OF JUSTICE!!
A-BFFZZT OOHHHHHHHHrrrrruuugggg
*wet squish landing* a-duh-dun
*as Freddy* No! Please! Not like this! No please!
It's too late for you! *scoop*
*Freddy* AAAAAAIIIIUUUUGHHHHH
Poof! Dead. Gone. L- I win!
You lose! Stupid loser.
*mumbles* Now that everybody's seen me play with dolls...
Oh!
Is that all you had to say??
Cause that wasn't as great to hear-
Ah- can- you- up- uh-
Can you help me? NO.
If that is what you're saying, but no.
Okay, so anyway!
That is all for this episode of...
Five Nights at Fromby's
I imagine any more aggressive difficulty on that,
like an actual 20 mode, would be a nightmare because
I doubt you can control him with that tactic like that.
So, yeah
I'm glad that didn't do what it was. But anyway.
So! Thank you everybody so much for watching,
there's gonna be more Five Nights at Freddy's VR
very soon. I'm getting better at it,
and there's a few more, uh, new game modes to plow through
and then if there IS a final hard mode,
I will address that as it comes by, but
each of these coming into it without knowing exactly
what to do is terrifying.
And I love it.
This is a really, really good game,
let alone being one of the better VR games that I've ever seen.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
check out the more Five Nights at Freddy's stuff I have in the description,
from other games, to fan-made games, to animations and stuff like that.
So, thank you everybody so much,
And as always,
I will see you, in the next video.
Buh-bye!!
♪ Shirk - Haunted ♪